a lot of you wrote in to ask if I think
Zynga board games are so evil why did I
buy them well I had to buy them daven as
props for my video rant also I had to
play test them and find out just how
evil they are so I could inform you
about them so if you think about it I
bought them for you raving Malkin Ted
rights Angry Birds and minecraft have
made real world analog copies themselves
Nintendo anatar you been making board
game knockoffs for years that's all true
and I'm not saying that Zynga is the
first person to do this I'm saying that
they have taken it to an infernal new
low Joshua durante says they're also
copying game publisher THQ's going out
of business plan zing hexa lots rights
tabletop games are finally starting to
gain ground again and you go and have to
find a problem with it Oh hexa lux I
don't have a problem with innovative
original board games and tabletop games
I have sponsored several of them on
Kickstarter I have a problem with
cynical knockoffs in my video rant I ask
you all to tell me in the comments
what's the most amount of time you ever
devoted to a social game mere 576 19
hours and 23 minutes Caden Welch 63
hours in about 20 minutes parrot flock
32 hours that is impressive and
dangerous kitne Alchemist has a
recommendation she writes you're
completely right now you should rant
about people's grammar on YouTube
comments ooh kitne Alchemist I believe
it's important to get angry and get
ranti about things that are important to
you but some things are just so
impossible so huge so difficult to deal
with that you just have to throw up your
hands in despair youtube grammar that's
one of them thanks for watching
subscribe to the wired channel and keep
the comments coming there's a lot of
stuff I'm angry about
what's getting under your skin make a
video and let me know everyone's got an
angry nerd in them